hey folks this is console crew and today
we're going to be talking about how xbox
live is changing its
name also is the ps3 in vita store
permanently
closing and joining you as always as
jordan
the xbox expert yo and the playstation
pro
and birthday bloodborne boy tomorrow
hussain
lucy did you get a haircut today you
look very nice i uh
i decided to keep the stubble and shave
i thought it would give me a little grit
and as well yeah thanks
as you know me lucy james is in fact
gonna be somebody else named curtin
davina
hope you like it deal with it
jordan remain you're the xbox creature
in this room
let's talk about how xbox live is
turning into xbox
network tell me about xbox creatures
creature i love that
i love that
it's like oh yes it's time to talk about
xbox today
xbox live's name is changing to xbox
network
but xbox live gold isn't
going away like that service is just
it's kind of like the whole
ea live ea play thing where they were
trying to separate the
names back in the day xboxes being like
look
xbox network is like the overarching
service and xbox live gold is
specifically the thing that you pay for
to play games online and to kind of add
on to this story
uh very like recently or i guess
recently for us since we're recording
this on
wednesday again who knows what thing is
going to happen
tomorrow on thursday or friday morning
that will make this episode obsolete
like always
but xbox insiders are saying that
they're currently testing a few new
services
behind the scenes before they go on to
the general audience
including not needing xbox live gold for
multiplayer and free to play games or
looking for groups or
party chat which honestly i feel like
xbox should have done that
years ago yeah it's
surprising that we're just getting there
xbox seems to be like so forward
thinking in so many ways that it feels
like
i i thought this was all already in
there at this point like i have to i had
to be reminded
by this to be like oh all right yeah
they don't have that right now so the
fact that they're adding it is like long
overdue
um i hope it rolls out quickly i hope it
rolls out smoothly let's
just keep it going um yeah yeah i mean
xbox has been
in this is as we know has been like
transitional
kind of adapting to its new identity for
a couple years now and i think
um it is it's about time i think you
know
the xbox live name goes away as
it turns into this xbox network which
makes a whole lot more sense with what
they're trying to accomplish when it
makes a whole lot more sense when it's
trying to focus more
on game pass obviously and at certain
services um
rather than leaning into what it was in
the first place which was like
the online chit chat machine now it's
like
the online everybody together network
machine
yeah so it's not all that much is
changing they're just kind of
delineating it better
um and you know they said that the
network
part of it like jordan mentioned refers
to the underlying service
um and that's been updated in their
agreement and then the
xbox live part of it is just
distinguishes
that from like the gold membership stuff
which is like i get it okay not a lot is
going to change for us
um
[Music]
here let me throw this question like
jordan how do you think um
like having it taken so long to get here
like what do you think the next steps
are in them trying to create this
this network thing like what's the thing
like how do you think this is going to
differ if
at all from what playstation is doing
with its ps plus and its services and
all that jazz
i mean honestly i don't think it's going
to have to be all that different like
this is kind of one of those basic
services that people have just
wanted for a while like the ability to
play something like fortnite or apex
legend something that's already free
without having to pay
something else on top of that and
which is just honestly just a service
that again xbox should have had
all this time it's something that i
think the whole
name change thing is weird but also i
think the further they kept going
without doing a name change the weirder
it would have gotten so this is kind of
just one of those pull the band-aid
off moments in hopes that people were
like look just
new console generation new us try to
understand that xbox network and xbox
live gold are two
completely different things even though
they kind of
overlap in a couple of ways i
assume at some point we're going to be
getting a bit more
insight into the like actual differences
there and i know that there's all those
rumors swirling around that's like oh
discord might be being bought by someone
wouldn't it be cool if xbox was the one
buying them
i'm not sure if i necessarily buy into
that but it does kind of open the idea
that
oh if xbox network and xbox live gold
are
two completely different things then
it's like oh we can
do our pay for these types of services
under the xbox live gold membership and
then everything that's kind of
like that you would expect when you pay
500
for a new console those just kind of
exist for free on this machine provided
you have a stable internet connection
which makes sense i think in terms of
games as well i imagine there's a lot of
publishers and developers now that are
very excited because
you know it makes business sense games
like apex games like
you know fortnight the stuff where it's
they have like mmo free trials of stuff
where you can get in and then spend more
money
it's way more enticing to people now
they're probably like people you know
respawn and epic are like great now
there's literally no barrier on the xbox
no one really has to pay for a live
subscription they get in they're more
likely to spend money on
our more likely to buy ryu for
uh fortnite and shoot peely in the face
with his
an actual assault rifle instead of his
hadoukens
and you know that's probably great
sounds so excited to get into fortnight
town
it's like one of uh this is like it's
the same equivalent as when batman
shoots guns i'm like
why are you doing this yeah but wait
until they throw a bloodborne hunter in
there
i mean bloodborne hunter can shoot guns
so i know
i'd be i'd be into that but like why are
you shooting guns
what's going on why is this world
speaking of growing pains other things
are changing tam
take it away what's happening to me oh
no you're talking about playstation
oh yeah yeah um no uh
yeah it's not 100 confirmed there's been
a report floating around
uh over this week that um
the playstation stores the legacy
playstation
stores the one for the playstation 3
vita
and portable maybe sunseted and
um the content that kind of is on there
will no longer be purchasable
um again unconfirmed uh sony hasn't
really addressed
this specific rumor um but i guess the
discussion around that is what it means
for playstation
what it means for people who
are on those platforms and to a large
degree
game preservation and you know game
preservation's
a big deal for a lot of people um
i guess you know we have another big
story from the week was
um a a kind of group has dumped a bunch
of data like 80 gigabytes worth of data
as part of project deluge which is
effectively like
prototypes and early gameplay demos and
you know like developer versions of
games like
god hand and crash and prince of persia
and a whole bunch of those like a whole
bunch of bunch of those games but for me
i think for us the more immediate
discussion is
basically if this is true we are sony
has created kind of like this
black hole in a large part of their
history and
everything from pre-playstation 4 is
going to get sucked into it
never to be accessible again for a large
group of people so i guess the question
is
how do you feel about that i'm bombed
out about it
mainly because sony has shown very
little
interest in preserving its own legacy
which is not a big deal but even making
it accessible
is is pretty they're pretty weak at it
you know there's been quotes previously
where jim ryan says nobody cares about
old games at all um and
he's right people aren't really buying
him but at the same time
you know if this happens no one will be
able to download
metal gear acid from the playstation
store or
you know what happens when i want to
play god hand
and there's no no physical copies
available and i
don't want to get my ps2 out i actually
just ran into this problem
um approaching the resident evil 25th
anniversary because
i don't own a ps1 or ps2 or even my ps3
anymore and on my ps3 specifically i
actually had
all the original six uh resident evil
games
purchased from that from the psn on that
console
and recently i thought i was like i'll
just pop on my ps5 i'm sure it'll be
there i'm sure i'll be able to play them
and they weren't i was there was no way
to be able to get
uh the ps the ps1 versions of resident
evil
residual 2 residual 3 and of course
racing 4 has been released 8 million
times so that's that's not a big deal
but it i've just experienced this in
this in this week being like hold on how
am i
how am i going to get these am i going
to have to get a ps3 again do i have to
go buy a ps2 and
do the good old backwards compatible
thing so
i mean one i've read once that a
developer compared
developing games to writing their legacy
in the sand
and every single time like one of these
stories happens it kind of like that
like
flushes back over me being like hmm yep
there it is
there it goes so yeah but it's one of
those difficult things like from a
business perspective it's like oh i can
kind of understand why you wouldn't want
to devote
resources to preserving all of this like
if
preserving uh previous generations of
games was
like what gamers wanted most then xbox
would be
dominating every aspect of every console
generation but nintendo and playstation
have proven it's like oh no people want
new experiences to buy for their
consoles
but at the same time like you said like
there's
like a tragedy to the aspect of
losing out on being able to go back and
play these games and admittedly like if
you find the physical copies of them
then yeah you can buy it like that but
physical copies are going to
skyrocket in price if these stores are
actually closing again we have no idea
if any of this is
confirmed or not uh i mean hopefully if
it
does come out sony playstation gives
like a bit of a heads up like in the
gamer's article they're like which i
think is funny like the psp and ps3 are
july 2nd and ps vita veto with life is
surviving all the way to august 27th
so it'd be nice to have like a month two
months heads up just so that people have
time to prepare for it
but we'll see i just wish sony gave
even just a modicum of about
their library like they just do not care
one bit and i i i mean like i play
games everywhere and for the purpose of
the show i'm the playstation
expert so like i have
i appreciate a lot of what sony does i
do not appreciate
its absolute recklessness when it comes
to
maintaining its back catalog and then
like i find
playstation now borderline offensive
like because
they create this this like platform and
this streaming service
has has some i'm gonna have to bleep
that out because it makes me angry
but like here's some garbage okay we've
chucked a couple of rockstar games on it
and like just piss off now it's it feels
so aggressive like and feels so like
it feels so like throw away like they
don't update it they don't add new
games to it they don't there's no
playstation one games on there as far as
i know
metal gear solid four is a game that has
been trapped on the playstation 3 and
you know
there's been i don't know maybe it's
behind the scenes but like that seems
like an
easy one to be like we managed to get it
for playstation
now because it's literally not playable
in any other way unless you've got a
thing
like put some of your games on there
even if they're first party games
it's like why does playstation now exist
other than to be like yeah we've got one
of those streaming digital things
and no one uses it and the the thing is
like there's no
you're right there's if the business
sense isn't there
like if there's no business reason to do
it there's no re
if you see that people are like not
paying for nostalgic stuff
then it does not make sense and i agree
with that but at least put in the effort
to give
people something that they might
consider pain
it's not like if if you roll up and
you're like hey i've got this empty
you know can of coke do you want it no
one's gonna buy that from you
like no one's give them something to be
excited about if like
if all the metal gear games came out
digitally on the playstation store i
would buy that in an instant
everyone would buy that in an instant
but if you keep putting like
hot shots tennis no one cares
about hot shots tennis sony or whatever
hot shots golf whatever it may be i mean
i care about hardshell
[Laughter]
but you know what i'm saying like they
put nothing out there they create no
enticing
like opportunities they don't invite
people they don't like
promote it and then they're like nobody
cares it's like yeah you've given them
no reason to care it would be
interesting to see if playstation would
have
more success with its nostalgic titles
if it had something similar to xbox
game passwords like here's all these
like metal gear games that you can just
play because you've already paid this 15
a month
fee and people will be like oh yeah sure
i'll just download it and try it i've
heard people talk about this game and
i'm
curious to see what it's all about the i
think the the last thing even
like the thing even even when they do
try to do it even when they try to lead
into it
uh we get stuff like the playstation
classic and that was like
not not good good
i mean like it wasn't good but you know
what given the
the the quality of everything there else
that they do
i i am glad they did that because i know
that i have this device which is a
novelty
and it's got some good games on there
and if you
are do not endorse this but if you are
savvy enough you can put more good games
on there
i i considered getting it recently just
because of
press t1 tekken 3. but like
what we're saying might as well just buy
the actual ps1 off ebay and the original
discs and call it a day and the thing is
like
we care about the legacy of playstation
we care about those
old games loads of people too i wish
sony cared as much as we could
or i wish they would at least make a
sustained effort to show that we care
or or like definitively find out whether
people are gonna put their money where
their mouth is
by giving them things that like it make
them think about
buying give them nostalgic old games
that are that they want instead of stuff
that
is like no nobody really wants this like
don't give them cdt games and then go
well nobody buys these it's because
nobody wants that
how else will they green light all of
the remasters and remakes though
and that's the that's the other part of
it like the strategy i see them doing is
like
you know oh no you know god of war
ragnarok
is out we've packaged all the god of war
games into this one
bundle which you can now purchase for a
full price
that's what i see them doing but you
know what just get rid of the
playstation now icon
on my dashboard because nobody cares
nobody uses it it's garbage and you know
it
everybody knows it just get rid of it
and there we have it for this week's hot
ch
[Laughter]
all right and that is all we got for
this week's episode of
console crew please apparently we have a
lot of opinions about some of the things
that are going on
playstation we're talking about you if
you have your own opinions which i'm
sure you do
leave them in the comments because we
read them we check them out we want to
know
what you think anyways this is it
i'm kurt not lucy james join with me as
your friends
jordan and timur and tune in next week
to see
if lucy james will return
you won't see me i promise